didn't have much to say did he let's get
the views of the former u.s national
security adviser john bolton who is with
us now in the studio good morning thank
you so much for joining us on the
program today what ramifications does
joe biden have do you think uh as a
result of the withdrawal from
afghanistan what impact is it going to
have on his presidency well i think it's
already had a very dramatic negative
impact in his favorable unfavorable
ratings that could spill over into the
domestic area this month where he has
3.5 trillion dollars that he wants to
spend but i think internationally it has
called into question his competence his
professionalism his credibility i think
the decision to withdraw was
catastrophically bad
and i think biden is suffering
accordingly wasn't his decision
originally though was it it was he was
just putting into effect a decision that
was made by president trump well look
trump bears a full share of the blame
here but biden could have changed the
policy he's changed other trump policies
biden and trump on this issue see eye to
eye they both want it out and i believe
it's both their responsibility
did the war achieve what it set out to
do well it achieved enough of what it
set out to do it prevented another
terrorist attack like 911 for 20 years
against the united states i personally
never believed that nation building was
part of our mission i think that we had
a geostrategic
reason to be there i think we still do i
think we're now very much at risk going
forward and so is europe
you say nation building wasn't part of
the remit but but if not then what what
was going to be left behind because
we saw what happened when the russians
pulled out they pulled out
in 1979 1918 a 10-year war uh pulled out
in 1989 and they were basically saying
it's a failed state we need to leave so
the americans knew what it was before
they went in well the objective was to
overthrow the taliban that had given
al-qaeda aid and comfort and destroy
al-qaeda we were substantially but not
totally successful the the mission
thereafter then creating a vacuum no but
thereafter the question would be what uh
society did the afghans themselves want
to build we set about building a strong
central government i never thought that
was necessary the key point is not to
help the afghans god bless them and all
that the key point was to protect
america and its allies from further
terrorist attacks once you get beyond
that it gets very difficult to contain
the mission and that's partially what
we're suffering from now given what's
happened do you think that uh america is
as safe now
as it was when you went in in october of
2001. no clearly we're less safe today
we are back in the pre-911 environment
and the idea that somehow taliban of
reform they now have smiling faces
they're going to allow women and girls
to have education and careers they're
not going to do what they say they
believe in
in afghanistan i think is a mistake we
can't know for certain but the people
with the most information are the people
of afghanistan and they're terrified
about taliban we had the uk head of the
army here where you're sat a couple of
weeks ago and he said we have to take
them at their word for now the taliban i
don't take the taliban at their word for
anything i personally wouldn't give them
air to breathe uh and i think we've
already seen evidence that uh foreign
fighters have started to come back into
afghanistan al qaeda never really left
isis k is simply another competitor with
taliban
and the idea that the taliban are now
more or less on our side against isis k
i think it's a fool's errand when you
say a pre-9 11
terror threat
can you expand on that for me well it's
not there today but it may be there soon
and the the circumstances are that you
have a terrorist government
in afghanistan now under the taliban and
as they did before they allowed
sanctuaries to al-qaeda and other
terrorist groups that's the threat i
think that we see again and from those
sanctuaries these terrorists could plan
attacks on the united states and others
so i don't see any reason to be
optimistic i think
moreover we have to look beyond just the
threat from afghanistan i think this has
had this decision to withdraw has had a
very negative effect for the u.s and
nato as a whole vis-a-vis russia
vis-a-vis china and others i think they
see this as weakness and i think they
will try to exploit it and you're
particularly worried about the situation
in pakistan
yeah look uh i think now nuclear weapons
with a terrorist government next door
the the risk of a terrorist government
in pakistan increases dramatically that
risk is already there
and if terrorists take over they've got
scores of nuclear weapons that they can
deploy around the world which is
frightening i mean you i want to just
quote you last week you uh told cnbc the
rise of the taliban in afghanistan poses
a threat of a takeover of pakistan by
terror groups it would be a catastrophe
if like-minded terror groups take
control of pakistan's nuclear weapons i
mean
that's scary stuff do you think that's a
very real threat well look i think the
united states has been concerned about
pakistani nuclear weapons whether in
onesies or twozies getting into
terrorist hands or the worst case
scenario the entire government
being taken over by terrorists look the
inter-services intelligence the
pakistani military has been paymastered
of the taliban for decades
their influence their radical influence
has spread throughout the pakistani
military which is the steel skeleton
that really governs pakistan so the
danger's already there i just think the
danger now is worth worse with a
terrorist group in charge next door
how did the west get it so wrong when it
came to withdrawing from afghanistan
because we were led to believe that
while uh the afghan army were not as
highly trained as potentially they might
be they were certainly on the right
track and they significantly outnumbered
the taliban so what went wrong was it
the intelligence that was wrong no look
i think people have misunderstood this
mission for a long time i i would never
believe that the afghan army was
america's front line of defense i mean
again i wish them well and so on or i
did because they don't exist anymore but
the real defense for america is america
and the insurance policy we had was a
relatively small military presence in
afghanistan
with a footprint for a larger
intelligence gathering operation
that we now no longer have it's better
to try and fend off the terrorists in
afghanistan than in the streets and
skies over america so why was the
decision made
because uh biden and trump together
bought the argument that they needed to
end endless wars and uh that there was
time for america to come home that'd be
fine if the terrorists had given up i
don't think their ideology has gotten
more moderate after 20 years in exile
and pakistan i think they have fought
they have now succeeded
why should they moderate now so it was
for a domestic audience that they didn't
want forever wars and and certainly the
american people had decided that 20
years was more than long enough no i
don't think the american people decided
anything i think we've had a long time
of failed leadership obama trump and
biden all of whom failed to explain that
the american people were safer having a
relatively small military presence in
afghanistan than to pull it out for
symbolic reasons and give the territory
back to the terrorists this was a
completely self-inflicted wound but it
was the symbolism of 9 11. it was we
need our troops home
before the 20th anniversary of 9 11. was
it that simple well i think in biden's
mind it was and that was purely
political there's certainly no military
reason to do it i think the uniform
advice of the pentagon and i suspect
many military figures in this country
was don't withdraw
and now there's a very um well
maintained
army if you will of the taliban that
have got so much hardware that was left
behind by the americans when they left
so they are quite a formidable enemy now
well i think that uh goes to show why
the decision to withdraw was a mistake
it's not just we're going to get our
troops back it's every other consequence
that flows from that and i think neither
trump nor biden fully analyzed it and i
think more and more implications will
become clear we've now got a situation
for us uk and others where hundreds
maybe thousands of citizens people who
worked with our military over two
decades are now hostages in afghanistan
and we will probably get them out but we
will pay dearly for it okay so we are
where we are you wouldn't start from
here as we say here in the uk what's
going to happen now or what should
happen next as far as the us is
concerned should troops go back in well
i don't think they can go back in under
a biden presidency so i think what we
have to do is try to isolate the taliban
if if need be put more pressure on
pakistan not to aid terrorist groups
and be prepared to take stronger steps
against pakistan but i think these
implications go well beyond central asia
i think the people of taiwan are worried
about what china will try and do reading
this is american weakness in central and
eastern europe people there are worried
about russia the russians that's what
they're worried about and in the middle
east many of our friends in the arab
world and israel are troubled about uh
the implications there so i think we've
suffered a very severe setback it's
repairable but we have to look at it in
broad strategic terms this is not simply
pulling 2500 americans out of
afghanistan it's much more complicated
and much more negative but you think a
biden presidency can't afford to go back
in to afghanistan reputationally i don't
think he has the dna to go back in i
think we've got
we're only eight months into the biden
administration we've got five six of its
left and and i think it's dangerous
times but there will be a big debate in
the united states over this i think
public opinion is already turning
against the withdrawal decision now that
the cost now that the consequences of
the withdrawal are clear and what about
the reputational damage for the united
states with its western allies
well i think this is uh again something
biden did uh
to himself after coming in and saying
i'm the professional that can clean up
after donald trump his first major
decision involving nato the withdrawal
of american and therefore nato forces he
did without any consultation whatever
with uh with uh with the british with
other nato members uh and and this this
is uh something i think that has cost
him reputationally within nato but it's
also led to the usual calls for more
european defense capabilities that's
another mirage the european union is
something that's
for a long time been less than the sum
of its parts there's a lot of rhetoric
about defense capability very few
resources if nato is weakened by this
we're all going to be worse off of
course he was here in the uk in june of
this year at the g7 summit in cornwall
um speaking about the situation in
afghanistan he then seemed to
unilaterally make a decision to come out
of afghanistan without having that
conversation and the other g7 members
scrambled to try to speak to him right
well i i think it's hard to it's hard to
understand how biden could have made
such a mess of it as i say he bears
responsibility with trump for the
decision to withdrawal but the execution
militarily and diplomatically i think is
primarily bidens
i can't let you go without asking you
about our special relationship with the
us and the uk we hear so much about it
all the time still uh we
have reached out to the us and said
let's have this travel corridor let's
communicate with each other let's be
able to move around and biden is saying
nope uh and he has no plans whatsoever
to make it easier for brits to travel to
the us do we always overestimate this
special relationship and it was only
ever in place when reagan and thatcher
were in power no i think i think it's
there biden is obsessed by
uh by the coronavirus uh threat i think
he's reacting against trump who
dismissed it i think they're both wrong
uh i think we are at a point where we
should have more travel and reciprocity
i think there are a lot of things that
need to get done i think the bilateral
trade agreement between the u.s
and the uk should be our mutual highest
priority it will benefit both of us once
we get it done
is he a one or two-term president
he's a one-term president i don't think
he's going to run for re-election
question is whether he makes it through
the first term so you don't think he'll
run for re-election i do not no i don't
think well to answer your next question
i don't think trump will run in 1984
either you've been looking at my notes
let me ask you briefly before i let you
go about 9 11. it is the 20th
anniversary do you remember where you
were when the planes hit and what are
you going to do to commemorate well i
was at the state department i was under
secretary of state for arms control and
international security and we were in a
meeting when the two planes hit the
world trade center i went to my office
which was on the southwest corner of the
seventh floor of the state department
and somebody ran in and said the
pentagon's been hit so i went to the
window i could see the smoke
and the flames from the pentagon i spent
all day and all night at the state
department working through it and
i i i will commemorate it very quietly
that's all okay we appreciate you taking
the time to join us this morning glad to
be with you thank you very much